I've been called lots of horrible things
online
always comment on how I'm not enough I'm
not black enough I'm not white enough
not gay enough the main ones are kind of
like transphobic abuse his his family is
not ashamed I bet your daddy's like
disgusted or not proud of you no matter
what you do online it was gonna be
someone commenting
people can just type something on their
keyboard and it can be in front of your
eyes of infected
I think growing up people thought I was
odd and weird I have been called a fat
diet cross I've been walking down the
street the word [ __ ] and [ __ ] is used
all the time to kind of degrade me and
my friends when were in public
saga I kept called a clown pileup
man [ __ ] you will never be a woman you
like masculine people also always call
me freak or vile or repulsive basically
any words which you can think of to use
against someone who doesn't fit a norm
they don't have to be put into a box to
be accepted see myself now as what
always what I wanted to be when I was
younger for me is like my biggest
achievement the best thing that I can
tell you to do is to really feel safe in
what you want to say being happy in your
own skin being able to dress how you
want look how you won we need to have
the required mentality 24/7
you